Hey guys, hows it going! its Justine!
And today we are unboxing something super super super exciting
Most of you guys know my friend Ro from Nerdy Nummies
She does an Incredible baking show
We have done
So many collabs here on my channel and on her channel and she has come out with a baking line so without further ado
Let's open
Oh my
Oh goodness there's so many goodies in here. Maybe I'll put this up
I am literally up against the wall right now, and I don't have any room to work
Okay, can I stick this okay? I'll just run off to the side and I'll just get items oh, I've got a little note!
This is so cute
The first items out of the box is a poo mold
Will you feast your little emojI eyes on this I've made a lot of poo themed things on my channel before
But this is amazing
I've never made a 3D poo mold you can make some brownies like some poo ice cubes some poo candy
this is
Probably one of my favourite things so far. I don't even know that's the thing until I had met Ro. I forget what
We're making I think we were making lego minifigure heads and had one of these and she said it was her favorite thing now
She has a Ro version of a candy melting pot. It's so cute,
It's a pretty teal color oh, I'm in love. Look at this. Oh my gosh. Oh, I'm so ecstatic right now
So what's cool about these is it will allow you to melt your candy melts or your chocolate or whatever it
is that you're melting and then once it's
Melted you can just switch it to stay warm you can just kind of like set it aside
And it won't harden up once you're done
You can let your chocolate harden in here
And then you just flip this the opposite way and just punch the chocolate out and you can reuse it
I had to dig through all the pink  confetti. I've got the items. Look at this, a cute little half apron.
This is so cute
You better believe I'm going to be booty shaking this all around my kitchen it's even got some oven mitts to match oh my gosh
These are so cute and look at the cute little tag like everything is so cute
Look at these little teeny tiny candies
here's little stars and the little lightning bolt these are little 8-bit hearts and
Measuring cup these are super nice quality
This is nicer than anything that I have in my kitchen right now, and they're colorful, too
Look at them! It's got a cute little grip right here with her little logo on it
And we've even got a little measuring spoon to match. I love it
They have like this little ring because I feel like every time I go to try to find a measuring spoon
They're everywhere look at these little cookie molds
The Little Cookie cutters. We got a little pi and a little 8-bit heart definitely want to make a little 8-bit hearts
This will be really cool
So I really want to start my Minecraft server up again
And this is going to be absolutely perfect for that. Let's open these up.
Come out. This is so nice!
It's like actually a nice quality feel because there's some little candy molds that are so flimsy
That if you put anything in it and try to pick it up it just like folds over. These are really nice I can also
Use this to make a Minecraft themed something some diamond. Oh my gosh
I think these might be some of my favorite things
These are a little cake testers. If you've ever made a cake before or the best way to find out if the cake is done
Is you shove like something in the middle of it and if you pull whatever it is out,
and there's, like, cake on it, then it's not done yet
We've got a little 8-bit heart and the cute little smart cookie. Yeah, I'll open them up. I feel bad opening and ruining her beautiful packaging
Look at them. They're so cute
I'm going to be testing cakes all day long. Thank you so much for watching and a huge
Thank you to Ro for sending me a few of the items from her baking line. I'm so excited
I'm so proud of her make sure you guys go check out her channel. I will also put a link in the description
Where you can check out all of her baking items. I'll see you guys in my next video
Let me know what you guys think I should make first. I am thinking I should probably make something from the poo molds because this is
Incredible I'll see you guys later